true or false the NCAA allows
transgender women to participate in
college sports as long as they have been
taking medication that suppresses
testosterone for at least a year the
answer is true the whole point of
hormone therapy is to help trans people
match their bodies with their mind so if
you're reducing testosterone your body
goes through the transition as well as
your mind true or false
federal law explicitly bans
discrimination against transgender
people in housing and employment this
one's false though federal courts do not
specifically ban this type of
discrimination some courts are
interpreting discrimination on the basis
of sex to include discrimination on the
basis of gender identity true or false
legally changing your gender invalidates
your marriage the answer is false
changing your gender does not invalidate
your marriage the only way that it is
invalid is if you have an annulment or a
divorce
just because you choose to change your
expression of gender doesn't mean you
have to change your life one another
true or false a 2011 survey 6,500
transgender and gender non-conforming
people found that 50% experienced
harassment by a co-worker
that one's actually true when my birth
name got out of my last job I definitely
heard about it true or false the North
Carolina bathroom policies are based on
previously reported incidents of
criminals posing as transgender and
benefiting from laws allowing
transgender people to use their bathroom
of choice this was false there have not
yet been any confirmed cases of
criminals attempting this even though
many states and schools already have
trans friendly policies I'm not sure if
Pat McCrory has done his research on
that one true or false
over 200 cities and counties have banned
discrimination based on gender identity
I never thought I would be able to say
this in my lifetime but the answer is
true thanks to all of the allies and
people working hard to change history
and to make it safe for everyone we have
been able to achieve this in 200 cities
and counties however that's only one
percent of the country we still have
work to do and we hope you stick around
to do it with us